you're recording okay look this is
Isaiah and this Isaac he's a little more
well yeah he's so cute
he's cool too but not cute Sub Zero Sub
Zero so like I'm not cute
be on my team
it's easier way
you wanna win
wavepad bus they make shine about some
way for you hang on that's better see
that's how you do thank you look full
emo going on going on my black doing
both hi welcome to markiplier the
Tuesday's there was some left in their
hair was in their hair do it feels weird
having hair in my face yeah like a
beggar than a school again you like my
new hair stuff pretty good enough you
stain mark you knew so we should all be
back from any pop con by now and I first
wanted to say thank you everybody so
much for attending we had no idea was
going to be that big you know we were
all talking behind the scenes saying we
were excited that it was going to be a
smaller man we're gonna have more time
with you guys we're gonna be able to
walk the floor see the exhibitors but
none of that happened and that's not a
bad thing for us but it's a bad thing
for you guys because we did not get to
see everyone even the people running the
convention had no idea that was going to
be back big because to put it in
perspective we had 3,000 people at our
panel which is more than we've ever had
at any panel we've ever done but that
number is actually more than the entire
attendance of indy popcon last year so
you can see how we were anticipating a
lot less and there was some
disorganisation about it I mean we were
trying our best we were cutting our
meals we were cutting breaks we didn't
take a break the entire time we were
there we were trying our very best to
see everybody and I
I think Jack Bob and Wade and everyone
else behind the scenes Mandy and Molly
and M's arcade and crank game plays and
all of the volunteer staff that were
there and all the people who are working
our booth we just wanted to say thank
you guys so much for working overtime to
try to get through everybody but in the
end it just wasn't enough we weren't
able to see everybody and that really
really sucked for a lot of you guys and
even the people that did get to see us
we felt like we were rushing you and we
didn't want to do that I mean we took
hundreds and hundreds of selfies and
signed hundreds and hundreds of things
but in the NBA we were just looking at
how huge line wasn't people outside the
line you know we saw some people crying
and we were just like everybody but in
the end we weren't able to do so and I I
wish we could have so next time we do
this we're gonna make sure we're gonna
make absolutely sure that we're more
organized
we might have multiple panel times so
that we can put on multiple shows for
everybody we might you know the tickets
might be sold specifically for time
slots so that only say a hundred people
fit in a certain time slot at a time so
that everyone knows exactly when they're
gonna be able to see us no one's
standing in line for hours and hours and
hours we're gonna try to make sure that
everything is better organized last year
without being said we did see a lot of
you guys I mean there weren't that many
people that didn't get to see us
compared to how many people did but at
least we hope that's the case because we
we spent like a lot of hours trying to
make sure we get the everybody but in
the end thank you guys so much
you made this bigger than we ever
thought possible and you know I really
am happy that we were able to be there
with you guys
I mean it was a lot of fun it was a lot
of fun for us because I loved meeting
you guys and I know I speak for Jack
Waiting Bob we love being able to see
you guys hang
you guys hear you stories and see the
cool things that you made for so many
people gave us stuff too and all the
presents that I got for my birthday it
was incredible the number of things you
wanted to give us and I kept saying like
aw do you want me to sign it and give it
back to you and they're like no no's for
you look oh my god thank you and then I
felt bad because I had to put it in the
giant pile that was assembling from like
birthday gifts I'm gonna have that ship
to my house and I'm gonna go through
each and every one of them individually
as soon as they get here but I just
wanted to say thank you guys so much but
more importantly it was Bob and Mandy's
first year anniversary they've been
married for a year so please go to Bob's
channel Twitter congratulate him and man
beyond one year of marriage they are an
awesome couple ideas one of my very best
friends and that's way more important
than my birthday ever will be and I just
wanted to say we had a great time too
because even though we spent hours and
hours meeting you guys we did take some
time for us and we were able to hang out
meet Jack wait Bob Tyler Mandy Molly a
bunch of other people we got time and we
were able to spend it you know getting
dinner I got to go to Cracker Barrel
finally again which I haven't had in a
long ass time you know a few months but
I mean I haven't had it in so long and
I'm you seeing that like every week so
just thank you guys for letting us do
that and I know it's sacrifice meeting
some more people but it was really
important that me and my buddies were
all to hang out and then we all went to
Dave & Buster's and we had a great time
I not haven't I see places where
everyone and it we had a great time we
played games we want to come to tickets
we got a bunch of prizes which didn't
end up being all that much but one of
the really cool things is we played air
hockey together and they had this four
player air hockey table and we did
record it I don't know
you guys want to see it as a let's play
of air hockey but it was some of the
most fun that we had because Tyler is
super competitive and really strong so
he was just waiting it across the way in
this one time we're playing on the
two-player table and he just when we
Hwang's it so hard that it flies off the
table and hits the restroom sign 20 feet
in the air like halfway across the room
it's gonna laugh if like some old lady
was rather than out shoots crunking out
of the bathroom you know how old grandma
you I haven't been hit with my grandkids
here that's not funny oh this is so
insane it was such a good time if you
guys want to see it I'll post a let's
play air hockey together and it was
really funny because whenever we were
playing with Tyler a bob kept saying
like word of advice Steve is blog it's
all and all thank you guys so much for
an awesome time in indy popcon we hope
you had fun next year it will be much
more organized and the next event that
we're going to is actually PAX Prime in
Seattle Washington it's not quite the
same as any popcaan because it's not so
us focused but still if you see is there
and you're going say hi to us we're more
than happy to say hi to you so thank you
everybody so much for watching thanks
for all the birthday wishes and be sure
to tell Bob and Miley and
thanks again everybody for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video oh by the way videos are gonna be
a little delayed today I'm getting back
to work and I'm going to go back on the
regular schedule eight and twelve
Pacific time every day I will not fail
you on that from now on I'm making a
promise to myself and you I will not
fail okay
sorry tomorrow
[Music]